[Music]
[Applause]
you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land
none of that ring it about and now
finally it's out the world has seen the
trailer yes
too true yeah good good I'm excited
grits out because people knew that you
were cast for a long time but we haven't
seen anything yeah exactly exactly no
I'm excited for people to see it it's
ramping up now and we're getting closer
can you tell us give us a secret a tease
of something that we wouldn't expect or
maybe we would expect there's a lot of
great stunt work in this that I'm really
excited about it was kind of my favorite
favorite part of the film and Niomi has
a new song for Jasmine that's gonna blow
your socks off yeah go on top of a whole
new world it's gonna top whole new world
you know I don't let any one song tops
any other song but it's but it's it's
new and it's amazing what was it like
working with Will Smith man wills
amazing you know he's the most generous
grounded person you can that I could
have asked for so he's he's great I
listen the role takes you to the Vanity
Fair Oscar party this is like the best
party at the Oscars like it's my first
time so you telling me you flying
already inside we've got Chrissy Teigen
John Legend Jon Hamm Miley Cyrus and
Liam just walked it I mean it's like
it's everyone is here great so mingle
[Music]
[Applause]